good morning everyone my name is Selena
I'm on Twitter as well my Twitter handle
is just my first name very easy so if
you want to share something about my
talk please mentions me so I can see
what was going on in the room when I was
talking my talk today is about how to
teach programming and if teaching at the
university has taught me anything it is
that early morning lectures really need
audience participation
so let's go who knows who said this
everyone should learn programming anyone
knows who said this Bill Gates
what our guess is Ellen K nice one say
were five five nine he's nice
so it's sort of all correct because it's
every programmer ever we all love
programming right we're all like
programming is the best so everyone
should learn it but of course this puts
us in a sort of interesting position
because many people then actually start
to teach programming so many people that
are programmers they run a code club or
they teach their own children or friends
or their children but how actually to
teach programming because most people
that don't really know how to teach
programming so that is the topic of my
talk today how to teach programming but
before we go into this I'm not an
educator so I want to take you through
the story of how I came to think about
how to teach programming and for that we
have to go back to the year 2008 when I
started to work on my PhD research at
Delft University in the Netherlands my
research was about how to create a DSL a
domain-specific language for finance
so me and my supervisor we envisioned
something like this a textual
programming language in which known
programmers could express themselves so
that they didn't need a programmer for
anything so they could create their own
little apps and programs to empower
themselves to run their own companies in
a more efficient or interesting way
because of course there aren't enough
programmers to build everything so it's
very good if we can empower users to
build their own
I started this PhD project with an
internship and an insurance company and
in that insurance company that works
many normal programmers so in my mind I
was like oh all those people they really
need my help
they're like help us Selena we need you
we need your domain-specific language to
help us with creating stuff on the
computer but it wasn't anything like
that I was like hello can I help you
with making programs and they're like
yeah we're fine actually we don't need
your help we are already programming all
those people the non-programmers they
were actually already programming within
their company if they needed anything
like a budget or planning they didn't
need a domain-specific language didn't
even need the they didn't need the IT
department they were just programming at
themselves but they weren't programming
in a traditional programming language
they were programming in spreadsheets
the whole insurance company and I saw
many other companies after that was just
ran by spreadsheets everyone was
building spreadsheets for everything so
they were sort of fine I went back to my
supervisor I said I didn't think they
need a DSL in finance but they have no
you know in finance
it's Excel it is it is just an amazing
programming language I really say this
without any irony spreadsheets are the
best programming language that has ever
existed in the history of programming
languages really thank you I mean it is
such a good programming language that
people don't know their programming let
that sink in hey imagine this happening
for Java is hey I installed Eclipse on
my laptop was super easy in Windows and
then I open it up and I immediately knew
what to do and I built this budget sheet
see how ridiculous this sounds for any
programming language you cannot just
jump into a programming language you
cannot even get it to work often before
example it works like that you just jump
in and start and add some data and you
know what to do because the interface is
really intuitive so my story at that
point became spreadsheets are code
spreadsheets are
a programming language and this is a
talk actually a similar talk idea that's
changed loop a bunch of years ago so I
went on to go to conferences because I
really like speaking at conferences so I
went to conferences I was like hello
everyone spreadsheets are cold I went to
share this happy news with all of you
but it wasn't so happy because people be
like that's not real programming and I
was like wait Lily Lily okay I
understand you're a bit skeptic but I
made a Turing machine in spreadsheets
using only formulas this must convince
you that it is a programming language
right
this is my Turing machine made with
Freddy formulas only so the rows are
different versions of the tape and the
head moves over it with conditional
formatting super cool I present to you
spreadsheets are programming languages
thank you for that but the people
remained unconvinced they were yeah okay
but it's not real programming because it
doesn't have this or it doesn't have
that or too many people can use it and
this was a serious argument people use
be cannot be programming because
everyone understands it really okay what
so it sort of went on like this and and
after a while I mean it really dragged
me down who in the audience has a PhD or
is working on a PhD quite a bunch yeah
so you know this but I guess other
people also understand this and you and
your topic sort of become this one thing
and if people say your topic isn't real
or worthier then you know you get sadder
and sadder and sadder really I was at
the end of my PhD I was I was ready to
call it quits with this research or it's
just I was just super sad and it it
really drags you down if people say your
topic isn't important and at this point
in time I thought okay this is just this
is just life apparently if adults hang
out with each other they will just call
each other's work shits that's just
normal little did I know I thought maybe
I should just you know tougher enough I
should just be
a bigger of a thicker skin because
people would just be mean to me it
wasn't until way later in 2015 actually
when I joined a running group that I
figured out of people can be nice to
each other this is what it took really
so I really like running and I joined
this running group but I'm a very quick
runner so my best half marathon is 2
hours and that's also the world's record
for the full marathon so I'm like twice
as slow and people there were people in
my running group where I did a half
marathon in two hours and they do and
half marathon they're like one hour tank
so they were way better than me but no
one in this group said you're not a real
runner Oh a half marathon takes you to
our that's not real running people will
never say that I mean if you put the
shoes on you're a runner people wouldn't
say things like oh you have a D - shoes
but they have security vulnerabilities
you know no one talked [ __ ] about each
other's gear I mean whatever shoes you
wear you can go barefoot you can have a
shirt or short it doesn't matter no one
is mean about anything it's so weird
it's even it's not even that we're
inclusive we are we're terrible is
anyone in the audience a runner advice
yeah so so we are terrible we want
everyone to be runners we always go
door-to-door like Jehovah's Witnesses
ding dong hello have you heard the happy
news about running it will really change
your life and we will make you such a
happier person we are like that if I see
you running through the bus I'll be like
oh do you like running do you want to go
on a race together what's your personal
record we are the worst I mean we are
the best we are such an inclusive
community yeah it is it's just amazing
and it's not just running it's also
missing I really night knitting I needed
a law when I was a teenager and I went
to university and I sort of stopped
knitting and then I came back to
knitting in 2016 and I went to a
knitting Meetup however times had
changed in
in community because when I was a
teenager everyone used these old
fashions straight long needles that you
might remember from people missing in
the old days but now everyone has
circular needles there are one needle
there rounds so I come to this meet up
with my old fashioned straight needles
and everyone has these circular needles
I'm like oh [ __ ] this is going to be not
real missing from beef vision I'm gonna
go home this will be terrible but it
wasn't like that they were like no of
course it doesn't matter we can teach
you if you want to but if you don't want
to learn it you want to stay with your
old fashioned needles that's fine too
Wow so then I realized that there were
other people that was we're all so nice
and inclusive and that it didn't hat has
to be that north real programming vibe
and actually it's getting even better
because this year there's someone a talk
tomorrow by Laura shank she has a talk
about CSS being a programming language I
was like wow people are so inclusive in
so many communities like strings Rubin
knitting and running it can actually be
different so definitely be sure to check
out this talk tomorrow
but let's go back to 2013 more it's 2013
again I am sad I have just graduated my
PhD and I went on a job interview at
Delft University where I also did my PhD
and in that job interview I blatantly
lied about being super excited about
spreadsheet because it was such a good
research idea to do stuff with
spreadsheets and they fell fertilized so
now I was hired I had to work on
spreadsheets with two PhD students and a
postdoc but I wasn't really feeling it
and I mean it's funny now but it was
actually it was actually kind of sad
because on the one hand side I really
wanted to work on this because I still
believe it's a very very valuable thing
to work on put on the other hand it just
it had worn me out so I was super super
sad by you total life-saving coincidence
at this point in time I ran into a bunch
of kids
in the community center that needed a
programming teacher so it's like okay I
will teach children on Saturdays
programming because at least I will
doing I'll be doing something valuable
with my life on Saturday so let's just
try and do that because then you know I
might not be working on spreadsheets but
at least I'm adding value to the world
but I didn't really know anything about
teaching at this point I hadn't had lots
of experience teaching at the University
so I didn't really have a strategy and
what happened then is I sort of started
thinking back about how did I learn
programming when I was a kid so this is
me I was about 10 or 11 I think I had a
computer I told myself programming I had
these books with basic listings so for
people that are a bit younger than me in
the audience
these were books and they had printed
out computer programs in them like this
so what you would do she would take this
book and you would manually copy it into
into the computer and then it didn't
work of course because you make many
syntax errors you fix those and the
still didn't work because you made lots
of different errors as well and then you
fix those and then you knew programming
was there no internet no there was no
internet there was no YouTube I got this
book from a library and this is how many
people thought themselves programming so
notice the absence of a teacher in this
story no one was actually there to
actively teach me programming I was sort
of teaching myself and by the laughs I
got from the audience I can imagine this
is a story that many people my age
children grew up in the 80s have
experienced actually a recent Stack
Overflow survey on about 90,000
developers showed that most people
really learned programming when they
were very young 85% of people that fill
out this survey had learned programming
before the age of 19 so more or less
before college so our whole community is
very much a self thought at a young age
community and that leads to the fact
that many people just let children X
or once they start teaching programming
they just have the same idea or you can
just give children listings they will
not be in basic they will may be in
Python or scratch but the children will
really teach themselves and what I did I
bought a bunch of books actually for the
kids in my community center and from
those books you can very much see this
vibe of children have to figure it out
by themselves so if you look at these
books the snippets will be in Dutch but
the translation will be underneath in
English so this one for example says the
best part of programming is finding
mistakes for that it's doing it's not
the best part of programming the best
part of programming is building
something right the best part of
programming is that it's a way to
express yourself maybe the best part of
programming is that you get to work at a
big tech company I make a hundred
thousand euros a year there are many
things that could be the best part of
her why is the best part finding I hate
finding mistakes I'm like who wrote this
oh it was me I hate this bubble it's
terrible
and what about mistakes well programmers
only learn from making mistakes so this
sentence is a bit ambiguous in Dutch it
can be people if there's a mistake you
can only learn from it or it could be if
no the only way you can learn is by
making mistakes but this mistakes
apparently is very interesting and it is
a way to learn or a moment where you can
learn but of course it also isn't
necessarily true because you can also
make a mistake and be like okay I quit I
give up this is too much but but it gets
worse this is a book for kids right 10
11 years you will fail often and it will
be frustrating so imagine like I'm
little Sally I'm in a bookshop I'm
interested in a new hobby maybe horses
horseback riding this book it has
pictures of horses are they eating
carrots oh this is very nice maybe let
let's try something else maybe
programming you will fail all for me
nevermind it is I know not saying it's
wrong but anything you learned will be
frustrating and you will feel often also
horseback riding but most books that are
aimed at children are more in the sense
saying oh this is really nice and we'll
do it together and we will practice this
is a special thing to say
this says never be afraid to mess around
an experiment okay that's that's no
terrible advice and break the rules I
sort of like this as a life advice
really but behold this book is about
Python same book this is Python a space
goes there a colon goes there a
rectangular Brecker goes there this
language for people that don't know if
you put a space in the wrong place
peyten will be angry so break the rules
but also this Python I don't know mixed
messages so of course this this break
the rules thing makes sense but at a
different level and here's the final one
most importantly it's fun so again don't
most importantly you can build stuff
that you really care about or you can
make lots of money now the most
important thing is having fun so this is
the message we send to young kids
programming is terrible break the rules
but also here's Python you will feel
often and you should have fun you should
like this pain welcome to programming
awesome
so you can really see that all these
books they're really radiates this vibe
of you just try it out you find a
mistake you fix it it'll be fun and I
did a survey actually recently with a
colleague in which we sampled 100 code
clubs all around the world and ask them
about their practices and we found that
71% of code clubs indeed have students
work on their work independently so each
kid works on their own project sort of
figure it out for themselves and the
teachers say oh you know we're just
there to help and if they have a
question we can let them know so it is
very much is the vibe that we found
in these Co clubs and this is very much
also how I wish teaching when I was
teaching in that Co Club I was like hey
kids here are some books I'll be in back
feeling really good about myself sipping
my coffee if you have a question let me
know unsurprisingly it didn't really
work well
the children were kind of frustrated
they were like well this is really hard
and I was also a bit frustrated because
I was like well I explained this to you
last week why don't you remember this
now it was really quite frustrating and
I was it wasn't very explicitly one for
self-consciously I was thinking yes but
when I was 10 I did all of these things
so why Cannot you do this it was it was
really very hard and let me remind you
that I really didn't know anything about
teaching at this point I was teaching at
a university so in a sense I was a
qualified teacher but we have this weird
thing in the Netherlands and I'm sure
it's sort of the same in the US where if
you want to teach in elementary school
you go to school for four years if you
want to teach in high school you have to
go to school for five years to be able
to teach in high school if you want to
teach in a university just get a PhD in
any topic and twelve afternoon of
didactic explanations and then you're
good to go
so I was a professional teacher but I
really really didn't know anything about
teaching and it was really interesting
because those kids on Saturday inspired
me way more to learn about teaching than
the kids for the students in the
university did because what's
interesting about an eight-year-old
that's not having fun and it is really
frustrated is they will tell you they
will take a book and thump it on the
table and say I hit your stupid Club and
I am never coming back
undergrads don't typically do that if
they are frustrated you know go to their
dorm and cry they won't tell you because
it's fun but there's also a serious
point that undergrads will have the self
image of that they're really smart
because they're in university and then
that they should be able to understand
everything and I have done some terrible
teaching University and I know other
people have so sometimes it isn't
about the student it is about the
teacher but you you do not get a
feedback because often students that are
older think it's it's about them so I
was very very inspired by the Saturday
kids to learn about teaching and one of
the things I read is the Oxford Handbook
of reading and this is a really really
an amazing book that summarizes for for
laypeople for know people that are
linguistics researchers how children
acquire reading skills and the first
thing that I got from this book is like
wow we know nothing we programming we
have no clue about how people learn
those people in in linguistics research
they know everything like let me just
take you through one of the research
findings I read about in the Oxford
Handbook of reading is that how words
sound really matters for your reading
ability so let's do another mandatory
audience participation moment because
you have to be waking up maybe so let's
do an experiment
what we're gonna do is I'm going to show
you a sentence on the screen you will
read the sentence in silence and once
you've reached the end of the silence of
the sentence you raise your hands so the
sentence perfect there's one caveat
though I will show the sentence to you
in two steps
so rather than at once first you got the
first part you get the second part now
once you've read read to the end of the
sentence then you raise your hands yes
are you ready to go
I have another one for you yes so what
happens there is your read I have a tear
and then it says in my friends and then
what you happy what to do in your brain
you have to go back you have to
reproduce the sentence in your brain
saying oh no it's not a tear
it's a tear they've done lots of
experiments like this and this proves
that even for adults proficient readers
the sound of words really matters we
know of course that it's matter for kids
if they're starting to read and they
sound out all the letters but this
effect remains if you're an adult reader
they know all of these things and
they've replicated this in Chinese and
Japanese and Italian and English and
Dutch there's so much research on this I
was like wow we really know nothing but
the second thing I got from these books
is that we like fights most really fun
we have enough fights in programming but
what we lack is pedagogical diversity
there are not different beliefs in our
community about how to teach in language
there are different schools of thought
about how to teach language you might be
aware of this difference between the
phonics approach and the whole language
approach so the phonics approach is
where you really deliberately sound out
letters read often these movements are
also made by children c80 get odds
that's this is how you spell out
languages so the people in phonics say
you should really first acquire all the
letters and then the words and then the
sentences and this is how you build up
knowledge on the other end of the
spectrum you have the whole language
approach and a whole language approach
says no no reading is not a technical
skill reading it's communication and
really belonging to community of readers
everyone reads so instead of focusing on
technical skills you should just have
children write stuff so the most extreme
version of the
gives children a pencil and says just
just write something so they're like oh
what is it saying and the child says a
unicorn lives in the forest of course it
doesn't say that but they're practicing
motor skills and then slowly they will
evolve towards our alphabet because it's
slightly impractical if everyone has
their own alphabet but the whole
language people say this way you gather
these the enthusiasm and natural
instincts of children that wanna write
so this is how you do it you and us
might be very familiar with something
called the math wars which is a very
very similar debate but in mathematics
so one side of the argument says if you
want children to be able to do math you
should just explain them how it works
and then they practice a lot first
addition and then subtraction and a
multiplication and you build up skills
the other side of the argument says no
no mathematics is not about boring road
practice mathematics is about building
beautiful proofs so you want to have
children explore the mathematical world
and the math that is in everything and
then you want them to solve problems so
that's the other side that's very much
like the whole language approach and
that made me wonder why don't we have
that debate in programming why don't we
have these two streams of what what
people think is the best way so that
probably has to do with the history of
teaching programming so I already heard
the name of the creator of logo it was
suggested as one of the people that
suggested that everyone should learn
programming so logo was one of the first
programming languages for children and
it was created by Seymour Papert this is
someone that many people know but what
many people don't know is pepper who was
a mathematician actually studied with
one of the most famous psychologists of
the previous century called Jean Piaget
and Jean Piaget
was the founder of constructivism and
the basic idea of constructivism of
course it's a very broad philosophy but
the basic idea is everyone construct
their own knowledge so it is impossible
for me to put knowledge in your brain
because you have to construct your own
knowledge and what Piaget said about
poppers is he said nobody understands my
work better than seymour papert's so the
history of programming languages for
children was very much influenced by
this constructivist view and Seymour
Papert is known to have stuff said stuff
like this by explaining something you
take away the opportunity for child to
discover it so this very much says do
not explain stuff to children and and
this is the vibe you see in all those
books so it's not just about we in the
eighties not having access to teachers
is also ingrained into the being of
programming education that you shouldn't
explain stuff to kids and this might
make sense but it makes lessons if you
look at teaching other things
specifically things outside of the
school context so imagine you have a kid
and they want to learn the guitar so you
you buy them a guitar it's like hello
Barbara congratulations with your
birthday
he is a Keith arm thank you mommy what
do I do with this I don't know kid you
just figure it out by yourself it will
be fun
I don't want to spoil the surprise for
you it's kind of weird right or you have
a kid the one who wants to do a sports
wants to play tennis
congratulations Tom here's a tennis
racquet and a ball or five I will tell
you how it works
there is no fun and you should discover
this so for all these things that are
not school topics we are all I guess
kind of convinced that lots of practice
makes sense if you want to be really
good at a sport you need a little surf
practice and also deliberate practice so
if you do soccer you will most only do
soccer matches all the time you will
practice you know kicking the ball and
running and I don't know soccer
something with balls and running
probably but you you will not do a
soccer match all the time you'll not
practice the real thing you'll practice
small things and the same with
practicing the guitar you will not just
do this one song you like
do finger placements and courts you
practice tiny things notice how these
things in outside of school contexts
very much look like this side of the
argument very much looks like deliberate
explanation and deliberate practice so
for out of school topics we all sort
agree with this side of the argument
beware controversy if you are easily
offended you might want to leave the
room now don't complain later because
I've warned you if you gather all these
types of philosophies exploration on one
side and explanation on the other side
it just turns out explaining stuff to
children actually works really well
there's this paper by a good
psychologist and the title is sort of a
spoiler it's cooled why minimal guidance
doesn't work you can read the rest of
the paper you can easily find it on the
internet it's actually a very
interesting paper but the title really
says it all this is a meta study so they
have studied studies and explain all
sorts of studies that explain quite well
that explaining kids really works so in
this paper they talk about this paper
that are really very much like it's
called the use of works examples in
problem solving by a researcher called
Jones Weller so what has this researcher
done there were two groups of children
and they had to solve an algebra
equation something like this you have a
is 7 minus 4 a solve this for a pretty
traditional puzzle one group of children
just did it like this the other group of
children they gave them a recipe so it
just said if you have a problem that
looks like this hey what you can do is
you can move to ca C times a to the
other side
and what you can do that and this you
can get the a out and then you can
divide and this is how you solve the
problem and then they got the same
algebra equations as the first group so
they got the equations plus how to do it
unsurprisingly I think this group with
the recipe did way back
because they got the recipe but they did
spectacularly better they solve the
problems in one-fifth of the time as the
other group so really quite quicker but
the interesting thing is that also on
new different problems they did way
better and this is of course where
people typically have against this type
of instruction they say yeah but if you
tell children how to do it how to do it
of course it will be easy but there's
also carried over to new problems and in
order to understand why it actually
worked like this we have to do an order
I'm sad to say this mandatory audience
participation moments but I'm gonna
sweeten the deal a bit for you because I
will bet some money so I'm gonna show
you a sentence very brief sentence for
let's say one seconds if you can
reproduce this sentence I will give you
a thousand dollars are you ready any
takers ok I'll do another one I'll make
it slightly easier for you another
sentence this one is easier so I will
bet a hundred dollars and do not make
pictures because that does not count
ready any takers
ok I'll do another one but this is not
for money because you will definitely
get this one I'll say my sentence I'll
show it same amount of time but I'm sure
you'll get it
so why each sentence is equally long how
is it that this final one is super easy
it is actually because our short-term
memory is very very limited your
short-term memory can only hold seven
plus or minus two items so between five
and nine items fit in your short-term
memory at the same time this is old
research from the 50s more recent
research actually suggests that it might
be between two and six items so very
very very small short-term memory
it is a miracle that I can stand here
while speaking and wave my arms if I
have such tiny working memory how is
this possible well this is possible
because your brain can do a thing that's
called chunking so rather than saving
individual letters or individual
characters in this situation you store
just three things because you see the
words Oh cats loves cake and then
there's three things in your working
memory so there's even room left
you can think all cats I love cats I
miss my cat at home or you can take old
cake maybe there's cake in the coffee
break I love cake so you have these
three things and you have room left to
think about these things while also
remembering in the things and that's
because you you've done a thing called
chunking you've made it smaller in your
brain and that way it can process really
easily if you would actually if I would
really have bet a hundred a thousand
dollars with you and you are actually
trying to remember this what happens is
you feel your working memory get
overloaded right you really want to
remember this oh it's a circle with a
dot and a stake and shake my reverse and
there's diamonds and a big C it doesn't
fit in your brain you you experience
this fullness almost and that fullness
is called cognitive loads so once your
working memory is too full you
experience cognitive load and this helps
us understand why this first group did
so much better than the second group
because in the second group the
cognitive load was too high so what
happened is the children were solving
the problems they succeeded in solving
them but there was no cognitive load
room left in their brain to actually
remember and reflect what they were
doing so they didn't memorize everything
after having solved the problems and the
biggest thing I think to take away from
Kirchner's and sweaters work is you
don't become an expert by doing expert
things like with the soccer example you
don't practice a soccer match if you if
you're training for a marathon you don't
do a marathon every day
that's a terrible idea but for
problem-solving it makes so much sense
and I've heard many people in different
contexts say this very often yeah but I
want children to be problem solvers so
they should solve problems but sadly it
doesn't work like that if you want
children to be good problem solvers you
need to make sure they have enough
problem-solving chunks in their brain
that they can rely on so my big strategy
from my research plan is to start a
fight I mean am I sign because I want to
talk about these two sides of
programming education because that side
has been over-emphasised partly because
of the involvement and historical
background of seymour papert's everyone
is talking about this type of teaching
in programming so I want to talk about
this type of teaching how would direct
instruction look like for programming
what could we do if we're really focused
on explaining children students the
basics of programming and make sure that
they practice a lot in the right way so
one of their research as I've done in
this direction and I am very very
excited about is we've been experienced
experienced in with having children read
source code elapse remember this
remember how much it matters how
something sounds in your brain for you
to interpret the meaning we asked a
bunch of children to read some Python
aloud just a snippet like this X equal
signs five what do you think this say
says children
X is five x equals five x gets five set
X to 5 assigning 5 to X it all makes
sense but there's no consistent model
for how people say this the interesting
thing about this study is we didn't do
it with random kids we did it with Dutch
kids and we didn't really anticipate
them in Dutch kids are in my country so
we didn't really anticipate this would
have enough
but a very very interesting thing
happened that we didn't think of this
letter in English of course is the I as
in time in Dutch my native language it
is not pronounced I it is pronounced e
as in creep so we have kids that read
this code snippets as follows
they said for I in range prints e within
the same code snippet and that of course
raises the question do they really in
their subconscious mind have realized
it's the same variable probably to your
turn
probably they haven't really got it
connected well that it's the same
variable so this is something we should
explore and it makes sense to say it
like this because Doge these over twelve
year olds Dutch twelve year olds know
some English so for the first sentence
the brain goes into English mode for I
in range well then for the next one
they're like oh so what does it do with
the eye details reading playing skee so
it makes sense that you have these two
modes of reading if you're a Dutch kid
but it will hamper your the readability
of source code if you don't explicitly
practice this so we actually did a study
in which we told children how to read
code aloud so really in a classroom
setting repeat this after me children
for I in range round open bracket for
round closing back at colum we really
have them practice the syntax allowed
and this works so the group that read
code allowed every week did better on a
syntax test after this course so they
were better able to remember syntax and
this is the paper if you want to read
the paper now everyone is angry with me
so my life has not really gotten any
better because people in programming are
really upset about this the first time
we submitted this paper it was actually
rejected and one of the reviewers said
this paper doesn't make sense because
programming is not about syntax
so what is it about reviewer - I don't
know so again this is this different
level
this is break the rules and this is
Python of course programming is not
about syntax but also it is because you
need syntax to be able to make anything
but how obsessive programming is is
nothing compared to how upset elementary
school teachers are with this results if
I go to teaching conferences and I talk
about this they're like ok lady so it is
2019 and you people in programming you
have fair doubts that making children
read stuff aloud actually helps their
understanding of things slow clap we are
so impressed thank you for this amazing
work dr. herons they know this in
education they know it really really
well it's we are the fools here they
know there is like not even just for
reading language it also for math like
how do you learn the tables of
multiplication one times four is four
two times four is eight how often have
you practice that hundreds of times it
just makes so much sense but as far as
we know we are the first ones to
actually have explored this for
programming syntax with surprising
results
so that is a thing that works another
thing revolutionary idea is you can
actually tell students how to solve
problems that also works really well I
found this amazing paper from 1992 some
people in the audience might have not
been born it is very old and this paper
is called the case for case studies in
Pascal is also easy to find on the
internet if you want to check it out
what did they do in this study these
were high school children they had three
groups the first group of children wrote
their own code as a solution to a
problem and then after they've written
the code they got the Sulu
that an expert would write as an
inspiration to learn from first group
second group same setup almost they
wrote their own code then they got
expert code to read but also they got an
explanation so next to the code they
were reading an expert would have said
well here I use a for loop and then I
use a variable this is the steps that I
take and this is why then the world's
also a third group they did not write
any code in the entire class the only
thing they did is they studied expert
code with accompanying explanation of
how you create code so these are the
three groups write and read code write
and read code close an explanation just
reading code pleasant explanation
the teachers very much preferred these
were programming teachers the first
condition they said first they have to
solve the problem and maybe then we give
them the X the code but not the
explanation but who actually did better
the second and the third group did
equally well so the group writing the
code and reading codes was explanation
did as good as the group that was just
reading code close an explanation and
the first group that worse and this
makes sense from the cognitive load
perspective reading expert code with an
explanation doesn't cost you very much
cognitive load you can just read the
code and and then oh why why has this
person done this oh there's an
explanation right there I can read it
immediately so there's lots of cognitive
loads less to store problem-solving
chunks to remember oh if I have to
reverse an array this is the steps that
I would take I can remember those they
will come in handy in the test so
there's those two groups didn't even
have a difference they did equally well
so you might as well not have your
students write any code because it
doesn't make a difference that is
spectacular
given how we currently teach in
university and in code clubs do not have
children programming I have them read
code and explain them how to code work
so explicitly teaching strategies really
really works well
the third thing that we're currently
exploring is assessments and then
specifically assessments in this code
club situations because in the same
survey I did when my colleague that I
talked about earlier we looked at
assessment and only 23 percent of code
clubs used any form of assessments so it
doesn't have to be assessment like you
get an A for programming but just
assessment in the sense that the teacher
has an idea of what children have
understood so we do these tiny things
now in our code club tiny tests which
one is a variable circle it you want to
set the variable points to zero which
one does that you can do this in two or
three minutes at the end of your club
just hand out a sheet circle all the
things and then you'll get an
understanding of what kids have
memorized and there's also research
suggestion that suggesting that if you
ask people to remember something that
will actually strengthen their memory so
having children remember this will
increase their ability to recall it in
the next week
plus you'll also get an insight of what
they know however of course here too
there are haters because haters are
everywhere except for in running and
meeting so people if I do this talk I've
done this talk a bunch of times at
programming conferences and what happens
is people come up to me at this one
conference a person came up to me this
was a guy there often guys comes very
close points his finger at me very close
to my nose says you're making it look
like school
is that a bad thing I mean school I know
their issues with school but in general
school is pretty successful most people
can read in most countries where there's
education for most children so I don't
know it's not terrible and this this
anti school is also it's also part of
our programming culture and we have all
these dropouts that are very famous
let's say you don't go to university you
can just start a work at a tech company
so against school so fits the whole
philosophy of this exploration so people
say it's not fun programming should be
fun remember from the books but I have
science it actually doesn't matter they
said what might be the second most
important takeaway of my song it doesn't
matter if people are having fun for
learning I go through this running group
every week so I go to this running group
hello welcome to running class we will
do 50 pushups not fun you know what's
fun lying on my couch watching Netflix
and eating potato chips fun 50 pushups
not fun so why do I do this because I
know it will make me stronger it will
make me quicker the same is true for
learning children know that learning is
no fun children already when they come
into elementary school have learned to
walk and they fell all the time not fun
still they went through and they may
have learned to ride a bike they fell
all the time not fun they everyone knows
that learning isn't necessarily fun
learning is hard work but still I don't
think that motivation somehow leads to
skill that is children are having fun
and I really want to learn that they
will learn this is not true there is a
relation but it actually more goes the
other way around if children are
learning is they are acquiring skill
they will be motivated I did the 50
pushups Hey I broke my personal records
yes this is working I will do more
children know this so this whole
learning should be fun we should
probably stop saying it because it's
very
about realizing you're learning
realizing you're advancing and that will
bring the motivation and not the other
way around
so that's more or less everything I
wanted to share with you but let me take
this opportunity to summarize my talk in
like two minutes I have left because
some people came in late and it's early
and you might be jet lag so let me give
you a second chance to get the gist of
this whole talk first of all don't be
these people do not be these people
don't say this is not real programming
because it's not necessary we should be
like runners everyone should like
programming and everyone should be a
programmer so please don't be these
people and and don't allow these people
in too much however before you do that
I'm actually together in Laura the CSS
algorithms lady I'm running a little
online survey so for once before you
never do it again any more we would
actually like your opinion how you see
programming languages on the spectrum of
least two most programming so we made
this web apps where you can put your
languages you can do this a secret and
you know no one looks at you while
you're doing it because if we want to
battle this together we should also
understand what is seen as most and
least programming and we have this open
text box also because we want to
understand why do you think this is it
about testing type system syntax we want
to understand this culture because
understanding is will be a more
effective way to change it than me
saying don't be like that so please
don't say it but fill out our survey
this is a link I will also have it at
all the end all the way at the end of my
talk the same link so you don't need to
do it right now I will show it at the
end as well will be very helpful for us
if you share this link if you fill it
out because we want to get this
understand this vibe of what the
community believes about programming so
this talk was about how to teach
programming because I tried it in a bad
way and it was not very enjoyable for me
or the kids mainly because I was
thinking of how I learn programming
which is how many people learn
programming and that was without a
teacher and this culture of not having a
teacher is very visible in programming
books and online materials that all say
just have some fun probably this is also
amplified by the history of programming
education because the creative refer
gaming education for children very much
believed that explaining was a bad thing
but now we know that explaining actually
is a good thing and there's ample
research and all sorts of field showing
that if you want children to understand
stuff you should explain them and this
is what we are exploring now and my
research group we're looking into having
children read aloud explicitly teaching
them how to solve problems and
explicitly using assessment also in
out-of-school programs the end if you
like to see more of my work including
all the papers that I've written there
on my website Felina don't come and i'm
on twitter i will also be here today and
tomorrow so if you want to reach out to
me just chat I'll be available in the
hallway if you enjoyed listening to me
you might also enjoy listening to my
podcast called se radio where we have
shows with other hosts every two weeks
about all sorts of software engineering
and programming topics as a radio one
question I will answer we're not doing
Q&A because there's no time but I always
get this question where people say have
you made those slides by hand yes only
iPad though I use an app called good
notes on the iPad I have drawn all of
these slides and I'm very proud of my
drawing skill so yes I have and then
here again is the link to the website we
will very much like you to fill out and
spread on the internet bit the leash /pl
- views will be very very happy to see
your results come in the end enjoy the
rest of chains loop thank you very much
you